One day, we will wake up to find that the energy that powers the alarm clock...
...came from the breeze through the trees the night before...
...and we will go to work that morning riding the rays of the sun.
It will light our cities and power our businesses.
It will warm our homes and cool our workplaces.
It will reduce sources of conflict and fuel our economies.
It will connect us all.
It won't scar the land or poison the seas.
The food we eat will be good for our bodies and good for the planet...
...and the weather that day won't make us worry for tomorrow.
There will be more jobs and less disease.
The sea level will stop rising and species will stop dying.
We can't wait until tomorrow.
This is our only home.
You can choose today to make a world of difference.